[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] en
raison de la nature critique de sa
pneumonie, elle a dû subir une
anesthésie générale et être placée dans un
coma médicalement provoqué et mise sous ventilateur
afin qu'elle ne soit pas éveillée lorsque son bébé est
né et n'a pas entendu le  bébé pleurer ou
avoir l'occasion de le rencontrer juste
après sa naissance et il y avait une inquiétude
pour cette patiente qui, compte tenu de la gravité
de sa maladie pulmonaire, que la grossesse
dans l'espace que le bébé
prenait dans son abdomen pourrait rendre
difficile pour  qu'elle respire profondément
et obtienne suffisamment d'oxygène, donc en accouchant
du bébé, on espérait que cela
améliorerait sa situation clinique et sa
respiration, il faut beaucoup de gens sur
de nombreux quarts de travail pour fournir le niveau de
soins dont cette patiente avait besoin et comme vous
savent que de nombreux patients qui se retrouvent sous
ventilateur avec
pneumoniae ne survivent pas et le fait
que cette mère a non seulement survécu, mais a
pu sortir de son fauteuil roulant et
marcher dans sa voiture et tenir son bébé
gi  nous donne à tous un espoir incroyable pour les futurs
patients et nos patients existants qui
ont
[Applaudissements]